Ngoài Hói Vị, Hôm nay ngày 18, kể liệu một chiếm 3 mây sấu năm ngày xin của chú tình hồ trí mình,
lãnh tổ thiên tài người thầy viễn đại của các ngặng Việt Nam, Anh Hủ Giải Pham xinh tổ,
Giang Yên và Thỏa Thì Giới, người trín sĩ cầu sản quốc tế mẫu mực,
người bạn thân thiết của các xinh tổ yêu trụ hà mình và tìm mộ xa hội trên toàn Thì Giới.
Người đã sành tròn cuộc nơi mình cho xưa vụ trang xa pham xinh tổ,
vì được lập từ xóa của tổ quốc, vì ở nò hạnh phúc của nhân dân.
Chụ tình hồ trí mình tên thật là người xin của xinh ngày 18,
là một người mạnh thẳng trăm tri mười trong một gia đình nhà nhỏ yêu nước tại xa kiếm lên tình nghe Anh.
Cục đợi của chụ tình hồ trí mình là điều tự cao đẹp về chi khí cách mạng kinh tổn,
tinh thần đặc lập từ chủ, lòng yêu nước, đạo đất, cần kịp nếm chính chỉ có vụ tư,
tắc phòng khiến tổn sản dị. Tư tựng đạo đất và phòng kế hồ trí mình,
mại là ngọn đốt xói đường cho sự nghiệp xe dựng và bảo vệ tổ quốc,
là tấm thương để mối cánh bộ đảng viên ở nhân dân nói theo,
họt tập, giản lịch, cống yến, vì một Việt Nam phát triển dầu mạnh khu cường.